E perdona si chiede potevo salutarti
almeno in italiano eh perché noi quando
siamo pieno così italiano snoy Trab Amos
tanto Golosi italiano sì tu Checco Qual
è il tuo Io l'avevo da qualche mese qui
a Bogotà e faccio l'ingegnere
informatico
bene informatico
informatori
ingegneri cosa vuoi tu da mia figlia la
vuoi toccare No no io la la vorrei
sposare in non la vuoi toccare
No no
sì sì no no nel senso
lasciami fare l'ultimo di persona Quindi
tu non l'avrei proprio mai mai giocare a
mia figlia No
ma se vi sposterete tu la toccherai No
ma non me lo vuoi dare a un nipotino
bello Sì o no nipotino o nipotino sì
Quindi tu la toccherai no no no no no no
no prescindere dal nipotino Sì nipotino
e se tu non la trovi
[Musica]
lo spirito la fecondazione
la inseminazione Santa